[Musique]
qui dit balade en bateau vie
consommation d'essence c'est sûr que ça
fait mal au coeur avec les prix qui ne
cessent d'augmenter la facture est salée
un petit moteur comme soit 260 force sa
cote en ce moment à peu près 70 dollars
de leur faire marcher robert va absorber
le coût peut-être qu'un jour il n'aura
plus à le faire
grâce au développement du moteur
électrique
vision marine technologies est le seul
fabricant de moteurs hors-bord à haute
puissance 100 % électrique au québec le
taux n'est mis pratiquement la même que
les avoir de sens de 95,8 dont on peut
parler autour de 200 $ aujourd'hui son
linge et de naissance un moteur moins
bruyant sans gaz d'échappement sans
rejet des sens dans l'eau d'embarcations
long le bout 6-4 en 2000 à l'heure près
de 50 km on en a tant qui ont sa grande
la cause de l'héliski beaux lots mais la
performance est beaucoup plus élevé qu'à
un moteur hors-bord comparable 175 force
à essence
voilà plusieurs avantages mais un
désavantage le prix uniquement pour le
moteur électrique de 180 force ou
chevaux-vapeur il faut débourser 100
mille dollars batterie incluse le moteur
à essence d'une force similaire lui
coûte entre 22 et 25 mille dollars sans
compter les sens patrick et distributeur
de bateaux électriques
selon lui l'industrie est actuellement
où en est l auto électrique il ya dix
ans l'offre pour l'instant est toujours
limité bien conscient que les grains
fabrica structure pour une offre mais on
voit aussi la naissance de plusieurs
nouveaux joie comme on a vu un peu dans
l'électrique dans le monde des véhicules
des voitures
parce que le potentiel est là
selon l'association nationale des
fabricants de produits marins 8,6
millions d'embarcation de plaisance sont
en circulation au canada mais seulement
une infime partie de ces bateaux sont
électriques alors pour moi la conversion
de petits bateaux ce serait une affaire
simple qui aiderait tout le monde mais
encore faut-il pouvoir les recharges et
de façon sécuritaire le propriétaire de
la marina de boucherville sipri barre et
moins je me suis laissée zié que d'ici
cinq à quinze fois que j'en fasse tout
pour l'électricité 90 voitures
électriques parfois grossir l'entrée
électrique avoir dit est sorti
électrique pour tout les bateaux
électriques ça vous coûtera corps x 100
mètres de large
le flou persiste quant à l'aide
financière accessible aux entreprises
nautiques pour l'installation de bornes
électriques quant aux subventions des
particuliers elles sont inexistantes
contrairement la voiture électrique que
ce soit un autre un vécu soro dans l'eau
ou un cas par cas qui est dans le bois
je trouve ça devrait être les mêmes
c'est le même programme disponible pour
tout le monde surtout seul qui veulent
convertir leur bateau jusqu'à moi
j'espère voir c'est que nos différences
nos différents parlers gouvernementale
nous donne aux postes dans l'industrie
que l'offre des chargeurs soit là et ont
aussi que ça ça va faire venir le
propriétaire avec son moteur hors bord
électriques avec son bateau électrique
et encourager davantage le
concessionnaire de tenir un inventaire
faire la promotion de ses produits
protéger nos cours d'eau tout en
conservant le plaisir de naviguer des
plaisanciers comme claude serait prêt à
faire le saut moi personnellement en
particulier oui j'envisage
sorti le motomarine électrique chez
canon sortie hume je pense sérieusement
à l'acheter je trouve que c'est plus
écologique qui avaient des subventions
comme avec les voleurs se seraient sans
hésiter on irait vers sol oui
il aura fallu de nombreuses années à la
voiture électrique pour s'imposer au
grand public l'industrie nautique rêve
d'une transition en vitesse ici marie
josée paquet comeau et au canada
montréal